foreign
is with us in San Antonio hey Adam
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking the call sure
what's up
well I currently live and work in San
Antonio and I just got a job offer in
Dallas now I bought the house it's
currently at about 320 got an equity of
160 in it and
a 3.75 interest rate now the job sounds
great but how much should I take as a
bonus or a raise to take this new job as
I know when I get a new house out there
it's going to be at seven almost eight
percent versus my 3.75
I'm currently making about 86 after
everything but before taxes and they're
offering you what well we haven't gotten
to the negotiations yet I mean we're
throwing some numbers back and forth at
each other but I mean I just know that's
gonna
take a lot more out of my paycheck
paying that extra interest rate every
month
well I I don't think you what you get
paid somewhere is based on the interest
rate of your house yes
I think once you get paid somewhere is
what the market value at the time of the
job is
my question is I mean if you cut your
interest rate in half
and you've got a one point
whatever one and a half percent rate on
it
um
you wouldn't expect to get paid less
no I guess I'm just asking uh at what
point is it worth moving
so um I I think you I think you've got
to back out of this
here's what troubles me about this
mindset it says it's like you're
uncertain of the job you just accepted
or about to accept and you're making it
their responsibility to cover certain
things this is a math problem man come
up with I need this much money to make
this move and if you can't work we'll
shake hands and great if they can't if
if the market doesn't demand what
they're able to pay in that area but
you're making them well you make it now
what would make it fun do you think
um with the work I'd have to be doing uh
I don't know 94 95. okay what do you
think they're going to offer you
uh hopefully around there I mean uh this
is doing what
it's assessing buildings after uh
hurricanes and disasters
okay and you're an engineer did you say
uh we do um forensic engineer work okay
assessing buildings hospitals after
disasters yeah I got you have you just
not
the main thing is I just know that's
going to take more out of my paycheck
every month sure but I've taken money on
that now I've taken several jobs in my
professional career at less money
because it was better for the season I
was in and it was going to provide an
opportunity for me to make like
significantly more money down the road
yeah 10 years from now do you want to be
in Dallas doing this or San Antonio
doing this with the two 10 years from
now you won't be working for the new
company or your current company
um probably a new one
probably what
the new one the new one okay all right
and so if you end up netting a little
less then I would and that's all the job
is worth
because I don't know what that's worth I
have no idea in Dallas Texas they might
offer you 140 for all I know
you know in which case it sounds like
it's arbitrary I shouldn't even worry
about this at this point I mean making
enough I'm comfortable I shouldn't let
that math scare me away from okay it's
short term
you want to make the decision based on
long-term variables not the short-term
variation but I'm I'm concerned as to
why you are hesitant to put a number out
on the table and say this is what it's
going to take to get me
I would rather them put the first number
out because it might be more than I was
going to be that's true yeah
yeah and they're all going to giggle and
be like you got it dude
[Laughter]
dude yeah why don't you see what they're
offering have you asked them Point Blank
what's the
no not yet the negotiation is just
beginning you said okay right yeah we've
got another one coming up yeah I would
talk about I would do it the best thing
you can do in negotiating in general is
listen
and let them talk and then just say gosh
I'm you know one of the things I'm
struggling with has nothing to do with
what the job is worth I want to come
over there and add value and the job is
worth what the job is worth but I've got
a real good interest rate and I'm not
going to have one if I'm moving and
that's kind of coming into my math so
what are you all thinking and just you
know that's kind of you know but you're
you know I I would not say
uh if you're coming to me I'm an
employer I've got a thousand almost 1100
people here and you say I I want more
money because my interest rate is higher
I'm going to say no yes because that's
not a reason for me to pay you more the
reason I pay you more is you're worth
more
not because or the job pays more not
because you've got a higher interest
rate you know that you see what I'm
saying the the value of the position is
the value of the position
and um and it might be that in this
shortage of Labor economy that we have
with a great resignation the way things
are right now that they're going to
offer you uh north of a hundred I kind
of think that by the way yeah it
wouldn't surprise me so I'd be real
quiet and let them put a number out and
then just smile and here's here's a
little negotiating tip just for fun you
can just play with this if you want to
mess with it it's a great little
negotiating line no matter what they say
just smile and go wow that's impressive
thank you so much
um
is there any more you can do
and just ask and smile and say can you
do anything else because they probably
got a little bit of something you know
just to see what comes out I mean is
that the best you can do I'm laughing
right now because I asked you that exact
question and you said nope
well I've taught this on videos and I
assumed you had watched the video
exact conversation I know right where we
were nope this is it this is what we're
doing